yeah when I first when I first was
sleeping with my girl like uh you know I
had to impress her so I would I got the
the honey pack from the gas station yes
you know what I mean nice beautiful
first month I was just I was on HGH yeah
dude yeah and then I know I always I
always like to go the first couple of
weeks with a new girl just sex with the
lights off
yeah because it's just you know I like
at least I get them hooked and then it's
just a full letdown because then the
lights go on and you're like yeah
because I'm one of those guys like you
know you know people always like oh you
[ __ ] you must be jacked but then I
take my shirt off my tits go like this
you know like I always have a crumb in
my belly button my dick has a couple of
warts on it and it's just one of those
things where you get them hooked they
fall in love and then they just start to
see pastors are you circumcised fully
served okay yeah but one of my camera
guys yesterday was telling us
which sounds like a name for a [ __ ] he's
got he's like we were all talking about
like how we were somehow we were in a
van in New York talking about our dicks
it happened and uh I was like yeah two
out of the four people were not
circumcised and I was like that's
[ __ ] gross right and then I was like
yeah no I'm circumcised but I'm like 75
circumcised okay what does that mean he
said that like they cut his dick and
then they like reattached a part of the
skin humor so part of the skin is
connected to the head and then he
started to pull up like pictures of
other dicks that look like his dick and
I was like bro ugh that's a rough
[ __ ] go for a young lady that's gotta
look at that mutilated [ __ ] meat
finger down there honestly even when I'm
watching porn
it doesn't matter how hot the girl is if
the guy's uncircumcised I'm like gross
can't do it next video what percentage
of gay does it make me that I have to
have a nice dick in the video here's the
thing here's what I'm about to tell you
right now backed by science I just
watched this was maybe a few months ago
I just watched a neuroscientist talk
about that men straight men 99 of the
time will fast forward or go to the next
porn video if the man's penis isn't big
because what excites a man a man's
sexual part of the brain are tits and a
dick that's what it wants to you want to
see big breasts and a big dick because
the subcon the little dick
subconsciously makes the man feel
insecure because they start to think
about their own size and it takes them
out of it they want big big huge dick
right with big boobs so hypothetically
the straight man would have the highest
climax off a transgender [ __ ] porn
that's the neuroscientist that's the
neuroscientist that I hired
um give give that lecture no that's the
neuroscientist that was backed by
science dude so it's weird you bring
that up that wait wait wait so
hypothetically a straight this is this
is real this is backed by science
this I saw a TED Talk of I was also an
event with my friends and I was like
let's look up Ted Talks on that can
verify that we're not gay because we
like females so we looked into it and
this is true you can YouTube this it
literally the the scientist said yeah
they did a whole study you know in
Sweden or one of those crazy Freaky
Deaky countries right where they were
like that men got most excited by a big
penis and a big pair of boobs right
because that in the in the core of the
brain you want the big boobs obviously
you want you know we know and why and
and do you know why actually big boobs
why where why we're attracted to big
boobs and a big butt do you know the
scientific reason for that I don't I
didn't know there was one I mean I enjoy
nice big breasts but I I would probably
fancy myself and ask guy but you know I
like both okay here's here's what it is
so the reason why you even asked the
reason why scientists say you like men
we like big boobs and a big butt wide
hips is the boobs one is because what
we're subconsciously Neanderthal brings
seeing baby has milk our babies will
have milk to feed off big breasts right
and comfortable pillow to lay on yeah
now now butt hips yeah wide birthing
Canal gives us subconsciously our chance
our baby's chance the best chance of
survival so we associate the butt with
the hips that's the reason why and
that's also the reason why women like
this all makes sense big guys why they
like attracted to a taller guys because
in her safety she's saying he can guard
me from animals he can go out and Hunt
he can go out and hunt and that's also
why men are attracted to more physical
attributes and beauty and women aren't
because what a woman needs is a man
who's all they really care about is if
they're smart enough because you have to
again we live in a different world now
but this is Neanderthal brain that we
still have you know are connected to the
man's has to be smarter that's why
they're less about uh physical qualities
because you have to be cunning to go out
and hunt and find food and right right
where the woman is not going out and
doing that so we don't care if she's
smart or not we just say dumb big old
titties
for a baby's breast milk and the big
[ __ ] and a big [ __ ] and a nice and a
nice uh nice wide birthing Canal that's
what it is if Kim Kardashian had a [ __ ]
I'd be in
have you seen have you seen uh my wife
follows this makeup artist
um Nikita dragon
she's an Asian uh makeup influencer but
she's she's trans right okay but like
[ __ ] smoking okay but it's like it's
almost like crazy yes you know what I
did actually my girl told me to look
into Nikita dragon and I did and we
reached out to do her podcast or if I
could go on hers it should come of mine
and she I believe her reps just sent a
one-word answer which was no yeah I'm
almost that's where I know her hard no
hard no and I'm like well I'm still
jerking off to you so can't stop me from
doing that yeah I always tell my friends
I'm like yo I can't watch lesbian porn
no there's nothing in lesbian porn for
me nothing there's nothing because I
like to at least feel like I'm the the
dude that's you know [ __ ] yes yeah
and I always I try to come I come like
time I come shot with the guys come shot
yes yeah yeah I
that's the strategy that's what I like
and I also like
an up close and personal [ __ ] I like
a [ __ ] I don't like you know if
you're eating a girl I don't care nobody
wants to see a guy at a chick out let me
see your wet [ __ ] dude
how many people you think turn this
podcast off or they're not going to get
the gold especially my my audience
they're like yo what the [ __ ] hey yo yo
he's suspect pause pause your man's wild
sucks
oh man